très vite et abdelaziz boumédiène
président de l'association des
commerçants indépendants des marchés de
france
bonjour a dit bhl d'elazig médiane merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt
france alors on n'a pas encore les
chiffres officiels sur le nombre de
personnes qui ont participé aujourd'hui
à ces manifestations mais de plus en
plus en tout cas personne y participent
est ce que est ce que vous les comprenez
oui absolument les corps pendu étant
donné qu'on fait partie de ce groupe
contestataire à travers toute la france
le peuple de france
qui se soulèvent contre une décision
absolument injuste et indigne de la
république dès notre pays deux pays
fondateurs des droits de l'homme liberté
égalité fraternité du gouvernement ni de
nulle personne même pas le fait dans la
public ne peut entraver la liberté c'est
les fondamentaux de la république nous
obliger à faire le pas sanitaires
lorsque je vois la dpa peu près une
semaine c'est absolument c'était
étonnant est choquant de voir des
personnes qui sont privées de
restaurants de cafés certains qui sont
privés de sport car ils refusent de
faire leur vaccin c'est absolument
inacceptable salle des rangs comme je le
dis à dans la fois le vaccin est une
solution mais de vaccin n'est pas la
solution va certes ici d'un vaccin
expérimental et comprendre la crainte la
peur la frustration l'hésitation deux
compatriotes ainsi que moi-même moi-même
voilà je suis dans l'obligation j'ai
tenté cette semaine pour pouvoir faire
un peu de sport et c'est absolument
aberrant c'est inacceptable et on est ou
que cette politique qui crée du clivage
on n'a pas besoin d'une image on a
besoin de rassembler tous les français
les français d'autres rassemblés lors
d'être unis je pense que le gouvernement
devrait plus sensibiliser les citoyens
donc les rassurer donc avec des vrais
rapports scientifiques
sur la nécessité et sur la sécurité du
youtube sanitaire est du vaccin
je me permets de vous couper 30 secondes
vous vous parliez de pédagogie de la
part du gouvernement sur sur justement
ces vaccins plus de pédagogie vous
pensez que le gouvernement actuellement
n'en fait pas assez
je pense que le gouvernement
par la sensibilisation par la médiation
qu'elle parle l'obligation de la
frustration on crut son n'a pas besoin
de ça se fait on a souffert ça fait plus
d'un an et demi qu'on souffre de
batteries sanitaire ça continue les
commerçants soupe je représente
association des commerçants indépendants
des marchés de france on voit bien que
la conjoncture
dégringole on n'a pas besoin que
clivages on sent obligé on va délimitez
collective on est 70 à 75 % de français
qui vont se patiner on va arriver vers
les 80 % on va vers les victimes sans
vouloir matraque et exploitant ses sens
c'est absolument incompréhensible et
surtout que là on se retourne vers les
soignants qui ont été ré d'une premier
jour en les menaçant de les sanctionner
de les exclure de leur poste s'ils ne se
bat pas c'est absolument incroyable et
je tiens à rappeler donc voir où on
vante les pays comme l'angleterre comme
les etats-unis comme une pelle je
rappelle qu'israël oblige la troisième
partie nation et israël qui était un
pays modèle au niveau de la vaccination
appelle à faire vacciner des enfants de
3 ans donc on voit très bien que le
vaccin est très loin d'être infaillibles
bastien a des failles il est parti et le
bâton
au delà du du du vaccin vous parliez
tout à l'heure d'unité nationale est ce
que vous auriez préféré peut-être un peu
plus de concertation sur le sujet de la
part du gouvernement de la concertation
du peuple oui absolument les gens vous
permettre de ma liberté d'expression
donc de condamner la position du conseil
constitutionnel mais quand je vois ce
qui la composent quand je vois me choque
pas de but on va pas polémiquer sur
l'île sans contaminer tout donc moi je
condamne la production du conseil
constitutionnel le concept ciel le
garant de liberté jamais jamais il
n'aurait dû ça signé sur la décision du
gouvernement il aurait dû condamner il
aurait dû s'opposer et comme je le dis
plus à l'heure ça ne sert absolument à
rien de créer du clivage on a connu des
gilet jaune la conjoncture s'en est
ressenti au niveau de la halle à la
cohésion nationale on a besoin de
cohésion nationale pour pouvoir avancer
pour pouvoir lutter pour coco but dépôt
pour lutter contre la précarité pour que
la misère on n'a jamais vu autant de
sans domicile fixe on n'a jamais vu
autant que pauvreté on n'a jamais vu
donc il ya d'autres sujets
soyons unis main dans la main c'est bon
nous l'écoutent le gouvernement doit en
prendre conscience et nous devons
avancer montre le copil 10,9 la crise de
communes 19 et contre toutes les autres
sujets qui sont encore beaucoup plus
importants comme la précarité la
pauvreté et d'autres maladies guerrier
égale cancer d'autres manient donc il
faut absolument qu'on avance qu'on mette
un terme qu'on en finisse avec le commis
de 19 et qu'on s'attaque aux cancers
qu'on sentait qu à la pauvreté la
précarité on a des milliers des milliers
de gens qui dorment encore donc c'est
absolument inacceptable donc nous venons
doit faire abstraction de ça de son
entêtement à vouloir obliger les
français à se faire vacciner et se
feront pas vacciner
ils n'iront pas dans les cafés mois la
plupart des gens que je connais votre
plus belle dans les cafés ils sont
privés de cafés et les restaurants
privés de convivialité prime et de sport
tout ça pour quoi pour en arriver où à
quoi ça sert voilà onze ans nous les
questions merci beaucoup abdelaziz
boumédiène d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui sur la très franche rappelle
que vous êtes président de l'association
des commerçants indépendants des marchés
de france merci beaucoup